Do you know about the EE system?
You'll have to elaborate.
I don't know what the EE system is.
So, if you could tell me that maybe I don't know that acronym.
He is using some kind of activator advantage and when I,
he does that feeling by fingers.
But then I would look at that's good.
Glad he's doing that.
You should have a work on the muscles that hold the neck in place.
Hold the vertebrae in place.
Have a work deal with posture, deal with sleeping posture.
You know, think about those kind of things.
You can also use a tens unit.
There's no counterindications with cancer with a tens unit that can really help.
With muscles.
The EEF can be really helpful with your muscles.
Other electro therapy can be really helpful with your muscles and go back to this question right here.
Don't forget to do the right on some different programs for muscles and paid and such too.
So, think about using frequencies.
Energy enhancement system.
Do not know what that is.
The top of my head.
Let me.
Look at a real quick EE system.
Here it is.
Yeah, I have to look at more of what they're used.
What they're calling the energy enhancement system.
And.
Looks like they're using.
Looks like different bracelets they have.
And.
So, yeah.
I have to look at what they're doing.
They talk a lot about scalar.
Fields and bioscaler.
Residents.
Stuff.
There's a lot of stuff out there that talks about that.
Some is hypercelled.
Different things that.
Do nothing.
Some might have very good benefits.
I don't want to knock what anybody else is doing.
If it works for a person, then that's great.
As long as it.
It doesn't have any.
Negative connotations.
I don't think there's anything wrong with any of that.